how's it going everybody
quick update on a rumor / report that
states when we could possibly see the
official trailer for Avengers 4 so
recently some international trailer
sources have said and confirmed that the
Avengers 4 trailer will come out in
November okay so we're in November now
but of course the big question is
obviously when when in November is this
coming out also I'm still giving away
copies of Infinity Ward Deadpool 2 and
ant-man and the wasp and some special
edition posters all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero okay so
according to the same source Jeremy
Conrad who said that the title for
Avengers floor will be annihilated
according to some of his sources they
say that it's very likely that we're
going to get the first trailer for
Avengers 4 during an NFL football game
on television and apparently this is
going to be at the very end of the month
first thoughts go to Thanksgiving Day
but since no games are going to be aired
on a Disney Network that's most likely
ruled out so Conrad says that the most
likely options would be Monday Night
Football on the 26th or maybe even the
game on December 2nd however he does say
that this is in no way confirmed this is
just what his sources told him could be
a very likely option so as of right now
this is the closest that we are to
getting an actual date for the release
of the trailer that and the title again
international trailer sources have
confirmed that the title is annihilation
and Jeremy Conrad himself even says that
he has six different sources telling him
that the title is annihilation so it
seems to be so but again of course until
it is officially announced we don't know
for sure nothing is set in stone but we
are closer than we've ever been before
so that's it for this quick report I
just wanted to make sure everybody knew
the information that was going around
right now let me know your thoughts on
this do you think it'll air during a
football game or do you think we'll get
it in some way such as Good Morning
America leave your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway
stay up to date on everything related to
Avengers for as always thank you all so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]